salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
alors aujourd'hui vous reconnaissez le
pont le pont on a fait deux morts et
douze coffres forts ou 13 je sais plus
en tout cas on ne va pas revenir mon est
revenu parce que il ya eu des travaux
qui ont été faits donc sarah rendre la
berge plus accessible de ce côté et on
va voir ce qui reste en tout cas on a vu
qu'il ya des gens qui sont passés on a
vu que des restes sur le bord du canal
bon bah c'est bien vous pour la
dépollution on va voir si vous avez
laissé des choses là un bel outil vol de
scooter
mais bon le scooter était dans l'eau
donc il n'a pas marché enfin il a été
l'autre côté avec le barbarian bon c'est
quoi ça qu'est ce que c'est que les
tricks dans une capsule de quelque chose
je sais pas du tout ce que c'est qu'ils
avaient comme décroché pour enlever ce
côté là ça peut être dangereux
après le fixe a ouvert des deux côtés ça
me dit bon peut-être pas dangereux mais
à cette ou ces percées la cbrc
ouais mais après ça c'est de la bouffe
aussi un ouais ça peut être des ouais
pas faire attention avec way
oui bah vu que ça souffre des deux côtés
ouais mais bon sait jamais non un audit
est bon ben ça commence bien ce côté non
c'est une canne de comment peux-tu muet
sur les voitures allaient celui qui te
faisait suer une voiture la voiture donc
la jeune sortir ça tu dois avoir une
bobine
ouais y'a très cubain sympa profitant
pour me filmer ça va super retrouvailles
aussi pas mal pensé que c'était une
bonne mais à la forme mais mentalement
sa portée mais sûrement fait main ouais
on dirait nous songeons pas sympa je
manquais l'opinel aussi du koweit - non
non si on a bien enchaîné l'a alors
comment savoir la marque way est bien
conservée numéro 8
ça va le faire ouais enfin si l'on
reconnaîtra pas assez cool
alors qu'est ce que tu nous sors encore
atteint la barre vois rien qui fait
quand même le plus gros four à pain
nouveau d'accord on nous avait échappé
tu l'as dit maintenant il ya quelque
chose je crois que j'ai perdu une partie
acheter sur un truc
[Applaudissements]
l'âge pas pu
tu crois que tu es sur la place à
moissannes bien quoi pour ce centriste
j'étais un méchant garçon on continue
sur léman tout ça pour utiliser le
barbarian a rappelé à la bouche mais
peut-être qu'il nous fait un passage
pour traverser jeter la terre parle il
est fou ce gosse sort de voir ainsi
thierry encore un centre à l'est
c'est rempli dédicacé du coup de fouet
aux les pinces à linge ou le simple
ouais eaux du saint nom revient là c'est
bon oui ça n'accroche pas bien ce truc
mais on les chope
ah ah
des trucs oui oh oui oh oui
cette chaîne là est l'erreur énorme
enfin on ne peut pas revenir à tomber
voilà donc pour ce qui est de la chaîne
comme on l'a dit zagg zag bijoux pas mal
ensuite on a petit objet sûrement
vénitien pour la bague et que nos
brillants
ça a vraiment l'air de fantaisie surtout
que l'anneau et attaquer donc ça c'est
aussi une bague donc c'est de la
fantaisie aussi le collier bof up aussi
et ça et ça qu'est ce que c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est
on continue sous le pont des miracles à
face b l'on tente quand il reste assez
fou il reste du calibre 12 ah ouais je
crois car la veille chip chip une
quarantaine
donc là on n'est pas filmé mais
regardez-moi ça un petit collier avec
des perles dorées sympa sympa
sympathique et donc il accroche pas
c'est de la chance ça s'est mis autour
ouais c'est vrai on n'a pas des pères
nara pour le coup c'est vraiment du
temps que je pense donc là j'ai un gros
truc qui vient
et c'est peut-être un coffre c'est
peut-être un coffre vraiment cette
voiture avoir assez lourd qu'est ce que
nous sort le barbare vote d'accor une
pompe
bayard c'est une pompe ça non mais alors
bon état ouais c'est récent date 2007
soit pas mieux pour une pompe par un
geste à loos s'appelle d'une non c'est
pas ça vaut peut-être cher 1 1
je les attends ouais je lui c'est bon on
va peut-être un cadran rien j'ai peur
d'être déçu coût financier dans l'acier
moins lourdes en guerrière dessus depuis
non non non mon sens où je suis las
canals j'ai quelque chose ce que je
pêche je l'offre avec vos détection a
passé six ans à si c'est un peu dur
quand même
on les envoie six nuls et ses longs
coupés au montage facile le veut
aussi
ce que c'est
donc on n'a pas tort
[Musique]
ah ah
qu'y at il au bout d'accord c'est la
tente avec la calebasse tajani a joué
dans le queyras trop perso en vrai ça ça
va nettoyer collection ouais t'as gagné
un tel amas de conneries ah ouais bah du
bijou la gamme politique de pêche est
quand même plus cher qu'ils ont perdu
il ya une prise a été au bout oh oh oh
chaîne à elle est pas belle elle est pas
mal du tout et la preuve que ça fait de
la place dans le contre pied la
d'épisodes elle est bien noir te va bien
bon on va les doigts jusqu'à sa maison
de la section toujours et que beast
magnetar ouais voilà
pensez à faire un tour on est très bien
rendue aux chocs à auch au bon là il
fait beau mais il ya du vent quand même
c'est pas forcément obligé de lui mais
c'est vrai que ça fait ça fait un bond
sweet aussi clairement en conditions
normales et surtout si comme nous vous
les remontées des chaises comme promo
pêcheurs de trésors qui vous offre 5 %
de réduction sur toute la boutique qui
fait toujours de très bon pour lui et
qui ramène les bijoux aux secousses à
ces boules là pas du tout ce que c'est
bon il est pas beau alors à brasser
coûteux l'offre
bon et bien côté très jolie journée
pêche à 1 le barbarian a tenu ses
promesses en a encore trouver des bijoux
suspens wen ont préféré ben voilà on
s'était dit qu'on attendrait plus mais
au final il y en a encore donc pourquoi
s'en priver sinon ben pour les
trouvailles pas trop habituel aussi un
pas mal de ferraille la dépollution
le plus intéressant pour moi c'est cette
capsule donc qui semble s'ouvrir des
deux côtés on sait pas ce que c'est on
pense ou une ration de survie mais ça
peut être des explosifs
donc on attend l'avis des experts dans
les commentaires voilà c'est ça on va on
va pas l'ouvrir pour l'instant on attend
vos réponses comme ça ce sera trente six
explosions voilà il faut foulquier et
cette magnifique opinel hôpitaux qui va
partir en restauration voilà parce que
il est plutôt pas mal je souhaite
conserver on arrive encore à lire les
inscriptions à la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle vidéo de pêche pièce bon
voilà donc les bijoux péché aujourd'hui
rien d'incroyable
[Musique]
ma fait exprès de ne pas le penser pour
finir de sa couleur d'origine de pêche
ah oui c'est sympa ça donne un petit
cachet quoi ça sert d'avoir un couteau
flambant neuf j'ai déjà vu ça dans un
film
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]